it's way too I was 18 to really fight me
like [ __ ] we had before a whole year I
just she's huge I don't feel good right
now
she bought a helicopter me yeah she
bought me father's helicopters
oh whoa Vicki damn kids are [ __ ] huh
yeah [ __ ] Jesus [ __ ] dude and then
that God Takashi six nine guy he looks
Mexican to me but he's claiming I think
he's claiming he's black right cuz oh he
says the word all the time oh and it's
okay no one's kicking his ass that's
totally Porter III Puerto Ricans he
looks like a regular Mexican guy from
East LA
means kids say that but Puerto Ricans
can how weird is that have you have you
seen him that is what you've seen him
before
yes songs were in the courses where he's
dancing that is part of the music yeah
he said you so much that if you Puerto
Rican down yeah I think guys they got in
six number-one hits in a row he's
killing it he has rainbow hair yeah he's
got rainbow grill he's gonna rainbow
grill now tattoo a 69 on his face and
the antenna and also that monster from
saw Jamie force me into watching him he
has he has 69 tattooed 69 times on his
body is that the one who told me that I
think let me see his face the new grill
cuz the new grill was off the charts he
looks like a dude from East LA and
meanwhile we're talking about him so he
wins yeah I watch every post
what trouble for what for pedophile for
a thirteen-year-old come on
yeah he's catching a case how old is he
that's what my friends say catching case
catching a case you like down the street
look he's got a spider web tattoo in his
face with that saw guy what's that song
guy's name pinwheel or something like
that pinhead scary [ __ ] though do you
know what see the new song with that
just that guy jigsaw jigsaw jigsaw look
he's got 69 on his belly
it looks like marker had a tits on him
he just lost his uh five million dollar
headphone deal because of what happened
at the Bronner fight what happened he
was
beef with Adrien Broner who's that the
kind of a boxer
oh I bet and I guess somebody in his
crew there was a beef with another
rapper and a gun went off road in the
backstage so it lost he lost his
headphone deal because damn it how many
million dollars was open five million
dollars for a headphone D all he does is
get on Instagram and just throw money
I saw it's crazy makes me watch and he
makes hits though that's where he's
getting this month is famous yeah six
number-one songs in a row
it's crazy world we live in and it drive
him nuts it's crazy world yeah go to go
to that middle one with his grill
look at that click on that a video yeah
listen listen to him I want to show
these how can you chew he got like show
me by Jimmy boy you know I'm saying he
flexed up on that one but I want to make
a public service announcement for these
past couple days I seem like there's a
couple females that are trying to expose
me as I'm sitting like there's a lot of
you like I can't even name sir is a lot
of you know like have a little bit more
respect for yourselves and I say that in
a way because you need to get past that
it was just like a one day thing you
know that hope you like what tough
where'd you find that go to Home Depot
is this music good I never know I've
listened to clips of like you know in
second clips I'm old enough now where I
don't know you'd have to it's not for me
go to Home Depot good people are loving
it they're eating it up cue door shuts
it's [ __ ] you'd have to call the
doctor you'd have to get a psychiatrist
I can't we can't play it'll give us take
it off for you too okay I can't I can't
afford that anymore it might be great
you never know here's my question if
this is ridiculous right what is what is
the next thing after the [ __ ] look at
this mother floss robot yeah this guy is
ninja and this hard good we still
looking for well we'll keep going
look at this [ __ ] on Ninja
Warrior man I'm super impressed with the
way this dude is traversing this I think
there are people that called cultural
appropriation on this
takeshi's x9 guy oh really what are they
calling on everybody making I don't know
this I don't know who's behind him
either
like the managers are behind him and
there's a couple other guys that are
making a shitload of money like him
is it oh is it a producer project is it
my planned did they pluck this guy go
okay this is perfect for our like you'd
have to really get a God it's one of the
tattoo his face you know mean that's
some [ __ ] that crazy right now
so many people have tattooed faces
that's some serious commitment tattooing
your mug millions of dollars yeah but I
mean it might not work and you're stuck
with 69 big days like an [ __ ]
I think they probably might wait until
they get that first big check and I
maybe didn't did he wait I don't know
about him particularly there's a
controversy between is he a blood or is
he a [ __ ] and he's claiming he's both
because I'm friend with both of them
something like that but he wears an
awful lot of red so people think that
he's a blood